one of queen of elizabeth ii's greatest
passions was horses she took up riding
age three and got in the saddle as
recently as last year she also famously
loved to cause horse racing and joining
me now two people who rode and trained
more than a hundred winners for the late
queen frankie dettori who wrote more
than 50 winners for the queen and nicki
henderson who was a late monarch's
racehorse trainer for more than two
decades well thank you both so much for
joining me i know how much both of you
meant
to her majesty the late queen frankie
where were you when you heard that the
queen had died and how did you feel in
that moment
well obviously thursday i was sorry it
was uh it was thursday was a doncaster
and i heard the news that
bucky and palace made a statement and
straight away we knew things were not
good
and then in the evening it was announced
that she passed away and uh
look i i know that i made the queen for
30 years and every time i seen her she
had this horror of
immortality so
when the news came that she passed away
it was a
feeling of shock a feeling of emptiness
not just me all the people around me or
the whole country really was uh
yeah i mean we were not prepared for
this and you know i know she was 96 and
you know
but nobody was expecting it just all of
a sudden and uh yeah it's really really
really uh
took everybody uh
by surprise and
you know it's been now three days
uh there is a
sense of emptiness
in the country a lot of silence and uh
yeah we
really uh tried to cope with it really
she was you know england's
mother but really
we're part of this country and we feel
you know part of it you know uh and you
know we are
uh tried to uh
deal with it
nikki you performing with the queen
mother's trainer and then the queen
inherited her horses you spent so much
time around these two great women i had
the pleasure of meeting both of them and
they were indomitable women in many ways
but their love of horses and horse
racing was very real wasn't it
well it was spectacular i think because
because
most of all we all know that
the work and the duty that the queen and
the queen mother herself beforehand had
put into the country and
horse racing and the horses i think
really owned overall were her one little
downtime hobby
pleasure something she really really
enjoyed incredibly knowledgeable
um
and it was
it was a very big part of her life
racing's only a very small community
really in the big picture
but she was our patron our best friend
and racing was very very lucky to have
her
um for all those years um
you know as as the biggest supporter
and and somebody who got so much
pleasure out of it and she just loved
the horses i think the people were part
of it as well
but um you know we just everybody will
have very very happy memories
of some some great days what was your
what was your greatest great supporter
what was your greatest moment with uh
nikki when you look back
i think really what does it say was an
enormous privilege and honor to be there
with the having had the horses for the
queen mother queen mother really only
had the jumpers and the queen had flat
horses so they sort of had their own
separate identities there when the queen
mother died um
the queen inherited the horses um
she probably inherited me as well i
don't know whether she wanted me but
i was there and
um we've we've had some wonderful days
and i think just i think that the sort
of a lot of the memories would be
i think the breeding side of it is what
she really enjoyed she loved the stud
the planning of the matings as we would
call it which stallions the mayors would
go to
and then the foals being born and the
dreams that were then born with them
and
i think the greatest pleasure is
probably actually wandering around
sandringham stud where they all lived
and were born and bred
and
you know looking forward to the future
looking at horses they were not going to
run for three or four years we were only
doing that earlier in the year and she
was planning for five years time
um and i think as frank said i think we
all thought she was immortal but sadly
nobody is and you know therefore we have
this enormous void and
but this wonderful country of that has
c served so brilliantly but now you see
that how much she meant to them yeah and
i think that has just been the last few
days have been unbelievable i completely
agree uh frankie you had 50 winners
can you remember one as being the
standout were you you had your great
moment with with her majesty
listen i i know imagine i knew it for 30
years and up to the last time i met her
i was
absolutely petrified to meet her about
every time i met her she made you feel
welcome
and uh she make you you know you you had
this sense of
great feeling after you met her and
obviously
my biggest win for her when i was
in my 20s
i was only a young boy and
but but the the feeling then you got
meta it was unbelievable and you never
knew how to kind of conduct yourself you
didn't know if you wanted to shake your
hands or to bow but she made you feel so
comfortable and
it was always uh you know even after 30
years you always have that beautiful
mystery and well-being factor that we
need when you met her she was a
wonderful wonderful person and if you
lost by a tight head
on a red hot favorite owned by the queen
frankie were there threats to take you
to the tower of london
well i did actually a few times but she
was always a great loser maybe
she was burning inside but she never
showed it she was always conducting
herself in in an amazing way
i'm sure nick at the fuse is the loss
for for for her majesty and is that
right nick
well she was you right to say not only
she was a very gracious winner and i
think we'd all sort of remember the
pictures of when estimate won the ask at
gold cup i mean the pure joy
that she had out of that
um but then the wonderful thing was when
things went wrong and they do with
horses they're fickle creatures
and they can't talk
um and
she understood them so if things went
wrong or horses or lots of horses don't
win so they can't always we're always
trying to get them to win but she got
enormous pleasure out of winning but she
was the most fantastic loser or the
bearer of bad
bad news um she understood
the horses and the people that were
with them and she she just
she made it very very easy for us
well there's no doubt that you two
probably brought more pleasure to her
majesty than
probably anyone i know actually because
the thing she loved was horse racing and
you kept bringing her winners time and
again so gentlemen thank you so much for
both of you for joining me tonight to
pay tribute to her majesty it will meant
a lot to i'm sure what you've been
saying so thank you very much